Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this week for
Game of Thrones bonus time I wanted to talk
about some of my favorite character pairings.
The show and the books are already very different
but it gives us more opportunities to spend
time with people.
It’s one of the only benefits of narrowing
down plotlines and cutting out secondary characters.
It just gives you more time with the people
they keep.
So these are my top 5 pairings from the show.
But I’ll try to squeeze some book in here
for extra context.
Oh and new round of the book giveaway today,
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Careful For Spoilers for everything through
season 4 on the show.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Jaime and Cersei
I always love watching interviews where people
asks Lena Headey and Nikolaj Coster Waldeau
about
Jaime Cersei motivations.
They’re definitely one of the most interesting
couples, and no matter what, I don’t think
either one of them will be able to unwind
their relationship.
At least completely.
They’re twins, so even if they didn’t
have a sexual relationship, they’d still
have that pseudo psychic shared twin space
in their heads.
I know everyone was really upset with what
the show did with them this year, especially
Jaime.
It did seem like he was on something of a
redemptive arc, cut to twincest over their
dead son’s body.
I don’t think it would have been very interesting
if Jaime had automatically turned into a boy
scout during the back half of season 3.
Not that the possibility is completely gone.
I just think that everyone in that family
is doomed to wallow in their misery.
Regardless of what happens to either character,
the Jaime/Cersei pairing is part of the bedrock
of the series.
The books go in a slightly different direction
after that big sex scene over Joffrey’s
body, so I’ll be interested to see if George
RR Martin backtracks in Winds of Winter or
future books.
Right now neither one of them is a confirmed
POV character in the next book, so we might
not get to spend as much time with them.
Number 4 - Jon and Ygritte
They spent a lot more time together in the
books so I was a little dissapointed that
Ygritte’s teachings didn’t become as big
a thing on the show.
They made Jon’s sexual education a big thing
but their relationship went way beyond that.
Jon had this really rapid period of mind expansion
while he was north of the wall.
If you’re looking at it from a Hero’s
Journey Joseph Campbell perspective, Ygritte
was his Goddess.
She imparted great wisdom.
Sexual wisdom yes, but also cultural wisdom.
It’s like being a foreign exchange student
and coming to the realization that you only
learned a fraction of the real truth of the
world.
In a funny way, you could look at the climbing
of the wall as this crazy drug trip they did
together.
Like they both dropped ecstacy and the process
of climbing the wall was the drugs opening
Jon’s mind.
And just as they hit the top and you get that
big wide shot south of the wall, Jon comes
to this big realization.
I think the sex in the cave was the same thing
for him, as was Ygritte’s death.
Now that she’s gone or at least physically
gone.
I’ll be interested to see the Jon/Melisandre
pairing.
I feel like that long look over the fire was
a big teaser for some amazing scenes in season
5.
I don’t think the show will take it to a
Gendry Melisandre Sexual place, but still.
Something is going to happen with those two.
Number 3 - Stannis and Melisandre
I always feel like Melisandre is playing games
with everyone, so even though she and Stannis
have a very toxic Jaime Cersei type relationship,
Stannis is always going to be the subordinate.
Let’s be honest about who the brains of
that operation is.
I think he’s completely at her mercy.
Jaime Cersei is a little more balanced, Stannis
always seemed to me like he was written so
that you wouldn’t route for him.
Sometimes I get the sense that in the narrative,
the character feels that way about himself.
Like history is being written, he’s a secondary
character and that pisses him off so he takes
up with Melisandre.
But he reekes of desperation and neediness.
Which are two of the most unattractive qualities,
so anytime he’s on screen with someone else,
you automatically root for the other person.
So naturally it seems like we’re always
supposed to root for Melisandre.
Number 2 - Jaime and Brienne
Probably one of my favorite tragic couples
on tv right now.
Just two people that seem like they bring
out so much potential in each other, but because
it’s Martin writing the story, you get the
sense that they’ll never get the happily
ever after ending.
There is no Disney ending for anyone in a
song of ice and fire.
That’s not a bad thing, I think knowing
they’ll probably never consummate their
relationship makes their scenes more electric.
I’m actually really happy with the way the
show changed Brienne’s character.
The’re a giant plotline that was excised
when they didn’t do Lady Stoneheart in season
4, so I’m curious to see if they continue
to go in a different direction with Jaime
and Brienne or if they circle back around
to the book story in a creative way.
Sometimes when they change things on the show,
like the whole Bran Karl Tanner storyline,
they still get to the same destination.
Bran still ended up meeting the Bloodraven.
I’m really hoping we get to see some crossover
between the Brienne storyline and the Sansa
Littlefinger storyline.
And I do know they’re making a few big changes
to Jaime’s story in book 4.
I do not think Brienne will head back to King’s
Landing even though Arya Stark slipped through
her fingers.
Speaking of which, my Number 1 pairing - Arya
and The Hound, Team Fuck the King
For all the changes they made in the story,
their arc in season 4 felt pretty close to
the books.
There were a lot of minor details that were
off, like the timing and cause of their split,
but Arya still came to the same conclusion.
She just stopped giving a shit about him.
I think part of the reason they were my favorite
pair is because they seemed like such an odd
couple, but they brought out the best in each
other.
Arya learned where the heart is, just a good
metaphor for growing up.
And The Hound found something that made him
feel like less of a dirtbag.
The Hound never quite crossed that bridge
so to speak, which is why Arya had to leave
him.
I know there are a lot of Gravedigger theories
that he might still be alive and get a measure
of redemption, but at least he helped Arya
evolve.
Two of my favorite moments just from season
4 in general were when Arya killed Polliver
and Rorge and I don’t think she would have
become that person without The Hound’s influence.
It’s also important to note that when Arya
left the Hound, she was just leaving him to
his fate live or die.
I don’t think she thought, “He’s Dead”.
She was just done with him.
But she did not cross him off her list.
He’s still on her list, so I think someday,
if he does come back.
She’ll still kill him.
It’s totally possible that even if the Hound
does survive, he could be completely omitted
from Season 5, like they’ll just not use
his character.
They’re doing the same thing with Hodor.
Let me know who you’re favorite pairing
is on the show and is it different from your
favorite in the books?
The World of Ice and Fire book is out at the
end of the month.
So in about two weeks, what I’ll do for
the giveaway is just make it for copies of
that.
It’s going to be a badass book, so you should
all buy a copy.
Congratulations to this week’s giveaway
winner.
Edward Faull, you win your choice of any of
martin’s books.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Lot’s of big stuff happening this week,
Arrow and the Flash are starting, so be sure
to check those out.
My next Game of Thrones video might be a theory
video.
I’ve been wanting to do a new one for a
little bit.
There are so many theories, right or wrong,
they’re just fun to talk about.
I’ll try to post that early next week.
Right now click here for my Top 5 Prophecies
and click here for my top 10 Dead Character
I want to see again.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you guys tomorrow!